ah
[Music]
you know what I hope this is recording
this time because the second time I'm
doing it and this is my midnight cap I
drank half of it I'm already a little
tipsy tomorrow I have a wedding to go to
and if you guys know me you already know
I don't [ __ ] like wax I have been
invited to dis your alone seven weddings
I've been pretty open about this but I'm
just gonna go ahead and reiterate this I
[ __ ] hate weddings here's the thing
it's not the fact that I don't really
like weddings
I [ __ ] hate weddings I enjoy weddings
to the point if I know the person very
well and the event that I'm going to is
personal to me
now the three weddings that I said no to
this year were people that number one I
don't really know so me making this
video and if you guys see it and you
guys were fairly upset at me for not
going to your wedding because I actually
said that I don't have a time for it
here's here's here's here's a reason why
you should calm the [ __ ] down
number one you and I we're acquaintances
you know this I know this ition offend
you when you see this in the video so if
I don't go to your wedding you shouldn't
[ __ ] care
and of course on to the next point
somebody you met once or twice they
don't go to your wedding should you
really be offended you're gonna have a
lot of important people in there you're
gonna have friends that you've had for a
life that's gonna go you're gonna have
your family and then you have some
random [ __ ] like me who says Amen I I
can't really make the time for it and
then you're gonna throw a fit about it
listen hey [ __ ] you
I appreciate you you're fun to be around
we really aren't that close to where I'm
gonna buy a [ __ ] picket to fly all
the way over to see you waste my [ __ ]
money to see you marry somebody who I
haven't even met what the but happy
marriages listen hey [ __ ] you there's
one wedding though this year that I am
gonna miss it's my friend Helen I can't
make it because I'm gonna be out of
country I'm glad you found somebody to
love personally I met him like for a
half a second but in a half second where
he didn't speak to me at all knee shook
my hand he seemed like a nice guy
I've been drinking at ha oh this right
here is my midnight cap by the way is
like half a grapefruit drink and vodka
if you think this is a [ __ ] drink
and I really don't give I can feel my
[ __ ] growing bigger by the way I don't
even take this video offensively man
like I just want to put it out there and
I've already said this to in person so
if you see it on this video you shouldnt
be mad but if you are still mad at me
still [ __ ] you anyways I'm running into
a bit of a dilemma I have a suit that I
have for weddings that I really really
liked I had a custom tailor to me and
everything like that
um it's gone tomorrow's gonna be a
fantastic [ __ ] day I'm tipsy I can
feel my [ __ ] growing bigger
[Music]
I'm not sure but it's like in the Napa
Valley area perhaps we have trees more
trees a lot of grass and more trees so
basically if we get lost year we're
going to die there re ooh if YouTube
doesn't work out I could be a horse poop
shovel perfect you ready to live that
life with me
[Music]
this is the product of Soylent here is
the best part what's watching you may
not have solid food but he still got me
you know right now right there you know
how was the ceremony
sir it was really short all right wasn't
it like me ha ha
there it is the man of the hour right
here made so I miss you so much I know
how did baby Chicago 88 Tyler aka
Skrillex aka so what do you think about
this wedding so far it's pretty cool
it's very chill very different I really
like it it looks expensive proposed to
you is it something that you would think
that you would want I do one live music
after seeing this I really like like
it's like I would actually I was
thinking that I want to be like visiting
the forest where we're not inside a
hotel yeah
think about it this is a very good idea
[Music]
so about to go inside to celebrate Canon
Victoria's wedding I gotta tell you so
far this venue is dope
the ceremony was dope the food so far
has been absolutely amazing they had a
braised beef short ribs they had some
salmon they had a lot of these roasted
vegetables I'm telling you right now
that's by far one of the best wedding
food I've ever had hands down I just
came outside so I could go ahead and
congratulate you and let you know that
whatever you've done in this you
inspired me to make my wedding just as
amazing and by the way the live music
[Music]
Viktoria Ken congratulations once again
dude I'm very happy to see you guys
happy it makes me happy to see you happy
and everybody's happy
I said happy a lot it'll make me happy
too right they will see so good I had a
taste and you know gigantic response
you're really good
and again all is variety like I want to
have this every morning so happy so it's
already been a pretty awesome morning
because just as promised we woke up to a
freshly made breakfast with bacon
hard-boiled eggs a nice toast with some
butter some cheese and everything else
to spread it was really great Joseph
thank you very much this trip was
actually not as bad as I thought it was
and after going to the last wedding it
kind of flipped my perspective on what a
wedding could be and I don't think I
hate them as much as I thought I would
which is kind of great like you guys saw
me in the beginning of this I was kind
of saying I really really hate weddings
they hadn't really been fun for me but I
gotta tell you I think I just went to a
lot of bad weddings so it was pretty
awesome looking behind us there's a golf
course there's a patio and if you notice
that's a [ __ ] bird chirping
nature that's how every morning should
be it's not like that in LA we'll be on
our way back to our hometown very soon
and I'm gonna miss this yay
[Music]
this is the hip-hop don't you like great
I'm Tony - ty good in question if I'm
real I'm so they kinda gone in the
gritty dick girls bullcrap that's your
life that's your your hip-hop
no it's about it's about having fun if
you [ __ ] way to get a rifle shower door
what's having fun just living life to
the fullest and what's that everybody
has a different interpretation of living
life their interpretation of living life
is partying and [ __ ] it just makes
me feel good it makes me really happy
why oh really what are your songs about
sushi and stuff Keemun ba ma ma ma Shiba
it's another honor - damn it better put
that autumn sir why don't you go me god
I think I make fun of your songs okay I
give you the respect and let you do what
you got I don't know the lyrics I'll
just filling it in uh-huh Keemun ba ma
ma ma [ __ ]
uh pushing on cause I'm a girl I don't
so let me come out like that I see two
all the time but Kimmy go to put the
Bobby
[Music]
all sort of all all these loans to
people who talk to
you've got my kind of more
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]